[Musique]
une visite théâtralisée en fait c'est
c'est une visite du château mais qui
sort un petit peu des codes habituels on
n'est pas simplement sur une visite
guidée où on va voilà nous présenter les
différents objets d'une caisse ou
simplement l'histoire
en fait là on a une vraie mise en
ambiance on part de la renaissance ou
donc c'est le comment le commanditaire
le tout premier à avoir habité ce
château est l avoir fait construire en
fait ils ont fini seconde guerre
mondiale où c'est donc le père ou le
grand père du propriétaire actuel en
fait donc donc voilà on traverse
vraiment les générations est vraiment
que le public puisse se plonger en fait
dans l'ambiance donc on a des costumes
de chaque époque on a des décors les
dialogues ont été travaillés adapté avec
les informations concernant chaque
période et c'est donc c'est vraiment une
plongée dans l'histoire en fait